thanks for
inviting us um both gary and i actually
to speak at the east conference right
now that was really fun
a lot of fun bobby and ben can you
unmute yourselves on clubhouse
am i yes
what's up everyone welcome to episode 26
of coffee and commerce
where we are testing something new we're
on youtube
instagram or rather not instagram
twitter linkedin and clubhouse so
here's how it's gonna work today we're
gonna start on uh all channels
and then we're gonna hop over to
clubhouse and interact with you so
thanks for joining us
as always we have the effervescent gary
vaynerchuk hello everyone
and we got two gentlemen that i admire
personally and professionally
ben shannon sapphire bobby kim what's up
boys
is this is this is this working okay on
clubhouse i'm watching it and it
looks like it's lighting up like a rave
yeah
yeah yeah it's like whack-a-mole but
okay
it's good we're all right we're good all
right so being fire away
commerce hi guys with the hundreds of
boys full fourth of five people
that don't know who you are you mind
telling them who you are and then we'll
get started
um yeah i'm i'm bobby and this is
my uh furrier uh counterpart ben
hundreds and uh we about 18 years ago we
started a brand here in l.a called the
hundreds it's a streetwear brand
it was a specific generation of
streetwear that was
coming alive online and uh our brand was
really centered around my blog
i was connecting our community kind of
researching our community and
broadcasting
with the rest of the world um we got
started just making t-shirts
kind of very much like a garage style
project we built it out of
our bedrooms and then it caught on
the blog caught on because it was very
early on the internet
a lot of things aligned nike started
rupturing more of their sneakers
a brand like supreme bathing ape like
these kinds of brands started gaining in
popularity
there was a downturn with some of the
larger urban brands which
if you want to consider or classify
those as streetwear too that was a
generation that was starting to change
because of department stores and whatnot
and people were really looking for
independent authentic voices in
streetwear and kids that really were
doing it um on their own and just trying
to figure it out so we had this real diy
spirit to it the brand was blowing up at
the same time as the blog
we opened up a bunch of stores fairfax
happened fairfax is
the streetwear capital or one of in the
world and we were
there from the very start and so you
know odd future those kids used to work
in those stores on street and hang out
there and odd future blows up
and frank ocean and then it just you
just blew
and you know the supreme thing happened
and um
we were in the middle of all that you
know and so and and now
we've lived many generations of this
brand many generations of streetwear
very recently we're entering like a
completely different space which is
more along the lines of crypto and nfts
and um which is you know gary and
we have we have been talking a lot more
about that but
that's kind of the i don't know ben did
i do it did i is that yeah i think so i
think you did more than
than you needed to yeah
which is typical typical i say more than
i need to
so guys so many of our clients so many
people out there they talk about
community they talk about community
after the fact they build
products they do stuff and then they're
like okay now we're either entering the
community or
we've got to create our own community we
got to figure this whole
content and commerce thing out i think
um bobby one of the things that you said
uh not so recently but a few years ago
that
was so compelling to me to hear you
talked about the brand and starting the
brand and the fact that you realize that
it wasn't necessarily an apparel brand
that you were starting they were
entering growing a community and the
apparel was merch
yeah so a few years ago i
released i published my memoir it's
called this is not a t-shirt
and in the process of writing that book
right so book publishers my agent comes
to me hey we want you to write a book
um i'm start writing the book and i do
like that like how anyone would write a
memoir i just started at the beginning
and halfway through
i started to question myself which is
why everybody should
probably at some point write some kind
of a memoir because you're kind of faced
with a lot of hard questions you're
looking on paper
going what am i actually doing here what
is the point of this it wasn't for me
just for money
and it wasn't just for power and glory
why did i build this brand
why are we doing all this every day and
halfway through the book i started to
realize
that all the stories i was talking about
were about these relationships with
people
and the reason why i'd fall in love with
fallen in love with street war were
the iconic class and these eccentric odd
figures that were behind a lot of these
brands the artists
and i was like dude it's all about the
people it's always been about the people
it's always about cultivating this
community
me being a middle child into
skateboarding hardcore growing up
being a person of color in a community
that we're just not a lot of asian
americans
all of these reasons right also just
growing up in the 80s and 90s
was always searching for community and a
home
and i never found it and so this brand
allowed me to create my own universe and
that universe was my community and then
i finally felt at home
and so that's what that was the
revelation and i think a lot of people
in that room bobby something that i
think will bring a lot of people who are
listening or watching a lot of value
ben please feel free to jump in you said
something into your story in the setup
of like
we were this new generation of street
brand because this
other generation was in macy's or and a
million other things you could go about
it
to that point what why do
brands and companies lose their way what
are what are some of the things for the
people that are listening
to watch out for if they've got a couple
things going well for themselves right
now
because you see it all the time in
non-cool places like your world
and then obviously hyper obvious in cool
places like your world
where you not only does your business
change the brand changes very quickly
um i think there are many reasons for
this but
uh the most obvious one and first one
that comes to mind for me is money
right and as you grow and
you want to continue as you have success
you want to continue to grow and you
want to continue to have success
you want to continue to make more money
um
and you know for our generation when we
started the brand
the the brands that started for us that
meant you got to sell to zoomies
i mean i'm sorry macy's and
macy's had the big dollars so you start
small and eventually you get
up to a place where you sell to macy's
and macy's is going to write you
millions of dollars worth of of orders
and that's what's going to support your
brand and continue to grow your brand
but that for us that wasn't success
right and um we didn't we
didn't want um we didn't think that that
was cool
and um i think that a lot of
look to be honest with you even if you
read bobby's book you see it
it happened to us as well right like we
wanted to get bigger we wanted to grow
and eventually we ended up in stores
that
you know when we started the company we
never wanted to sell to a store like
zoomies or pacsun
these urban outfitters like these big
mall based
chain stores we never wanted to do that
but
we felt we needed to in order to grow
the business and continue to grow the
business
yeah go ahead bobby oh i didn't mean to
interrupt but
i think i know where this question is
going actually because it makes a lot of
sense
with the theme of today and this the
topic of the discussion
but i feel like this is a conversation
really about gatekeepers right
and so in the 80s the 70s 80s if you
were an apparel brand
and you wanted to get big and you wanted
to reach an audience you had to rely on
the gatekeepers those were stores like
macy's uh i forget all the names of
these stores ben like the older ones the
bigger departments of course and then
what's our scaled
distribution scale distribution and
whether or not whether it was
whether that was macy's or itv
because exactly too short right
like literally watch this there it is
this is what my skin always does
look what happens with my goosebumps the
reason i feel the way about davis on
clubhouse everybody sorry clubhouse
gary
the second i said the word too short
here's why
never did mainstream no because he
wasn't going to be on
mtv never did mainstream
no because he was never going to be on
z100 on east coast
right right but scale
through sheer forever authenticity
right and building a community his own
community right correct
those tapes were [ __ ] crazy
i i hate you bobby because you're smart
and you saw
you saw my three set up chest move to
what i want because i only got i only
got 15 more minutes
that's exactly right there was like
there even with the internet
which was a massive advancement
yeah in the ability to have unlimited
gatekeepers
the cost of entry to be a gatekeeper was
different and so the gatekeepers
myspace facebook twitter tumblr
spotify soundcloud like there's a lot
more already
all they were were the internet has so
many more
opportunities for so many more
gatekeepers
that it made it seem more democracy here
comes social
absolutely true absolutely true i'm a
byproduct of it
you know then you know bobby like to me
it's crazy how much money i've left on
the table
like to myself as a businessman to stay
in a lane that i want to be happy with
and
and all of a sudden here comes
defy here comes blockchain
here comes an nfc and what we're about
to see
is going to be scary scary big yeah yeah
yeah so i feel like there were
gatekeepers that were these department
stores for our generation
they were more or less the mall door
stores like active ride shop
but we still had to rely on them to
access customers sales wise and
marketing wise
right there are still gatekeepers there
the generation right after us of
streetwear brands
they had ecom and they had dtc
and they could build their entire brand
without ever having speak through a
gatekeeper and that was their advantage
and we
just missed that but now we're getting
to a space where
you can avoid the you can walk around
the gatekeeper
circumnavigate them on the sales end and
the marketing end
right you can sell to them directly and
you can just go directly
through to your customers by use of the
blockchain
or nfts or whatever so it's like this is
the best
possible scenario for brands and
designers is like
we can hold on to all our integrity we
can get 100 of the money
and we can speak to whoever we want we
can sell to you know what's funny
you know who's you know who's gonna
share in the money versus the 100 of the
money the people that know how to
cultivate attention
yeah you know there will be people like
this is
i'm like really sitting in the weeds
like uh oh
this whole dream i've had for myself
might be here quicker than i thought
right because all i've been doing is
eating [ __ ] for 15 years building this
machine
that can take attention arbitrage to a
different place even with the most
talented
to me that's you know you're gonna like
even the people like
cool you can do an nft do you know how
to strategize how to launch it
do you know how to make it last for 40
years do you know how to do the gaming
mechanics oh by the way
do you know how to get people to even
know it exists like it's very nice that
you have an nft
where's your audience like yeah so so i
i think you're right
and i think the you know i view myself
and what i'm trying to build as almost
like what
mtv and radio stu you know distribution
and virgin super slick to me it's like
can you be the most valuable and
what i love about the way i think about
it is and i want way less money
like my relationship with whatever it is
i want them to get a lot of the value
artists
got the smallest piece distribution
management
sale like the person that created it
when it was all said and done
after this [ __ ] sold especially art art
not like a cd but like art
like by the time you you were getting
nickels and dimes
on the dollar for me
i'm gonna bring way more value than all
those things did or i'm gonna represent
that value
through like partnership in through
these worlds but i'm only gonna want a
tiny piece
that's crazy yeah that's
also because you realize it's not a
zero-sum game right correct
i live in 51.49 all i care about is
can i give 51 or greater of value to any
human i interact with
from a karma or a business relationship
and if i can be a hundred and zero i'm
the happiest
because all that means is good if you're
gonna if you're
like i don't need [ __ ] i don't want [ __ ]
i don't need [ __ ]
i don't want [ __ ] now in my older age
i'm like oh [ __ ]
i do build resentments sometimes so i
have to develop kind
candor because i have resentment and
then i bounce and then people are
stunned because i didn't forewarn them
that i've been giving all the value
and i'm out like you know and so i've
had to evolve
but my natural state is not being
interested in anything
thus i've always had this incredible
leverage of relationship
because i'm overwhelmingly trying to
figure out how to bring more value than
get in return
that's why i've done well in my
businesses right i'm trying to sell you
a wine that costs you less than what you
came in for that's better
might be less profitable for me but now
you're like yo i [ __ ] with that kid
i came in for kms for 50 bucks he sold
me some cab that's better at 28 who is
this kid that's how i built my company
and then who i am as like a content
producer right
i'm coming out and i feel confident
saying this i spit facts and give value
and engage
at a level that's tippy top of the game
with no
alternative motive to my audience that's
big
it's different but that's also why you
get along with these guys so well right
because they're the same look at what
they've done with their communities
forget about get along i admire them
from before
you know same same guys yeah a little
bit around
your community building um what you've
done for the community what you're doing
for the community and
the fact that it ultimately benefits the
hundreds and how the hundreds has
evolved from
kind of ebbed and flowed from a
as you put it like a merch line for a
community to
a an apparel brand of itself to what
you're doing with family style i mean
there's just so much you guys are doing
uh i mean i can talk about it but
honestly like this is
right your cup of tea bob yeah well
um look upon the epiphany that
this is really just about the community
and cultivating community we took
a look at and we had spoke a little bit
about this on before we started
jumping on the call but we had spent so
many years building a brand
that it when you build a brand you're so
in it
uh why the reason why you're doing it is
because you want to be heard right
you're building your own stage you're
like i want people to look at me i want
people to
hear what i have to say that i want them
to understand my opinions
and then you get to you build this brand
and then you're like what do i do with
this now
right and i've kind of said my piece
people
know my story what do we use this stage
for we have this beautiful platform we
have the main stage at coachella
well for us we looked around and we
realized well this is the
the a prime opportunity to get other
people the
the microphone and the megaphone so
anybody who
is deserving of the attention needs the
limelight needs the
needs the audience why don't you walk up
here on stage with us
you know so that's collaborators from
young artists and
independent brands that are social
though that's also
is social causes right whether it's
us working with indigenous communities
around north america which we did um
for a year with a bunch of indigenous
brands you know late now we're using it
to talk more about asian american issues
um last year it might have been more uh
around the black community so um
another great example of this i would
say is a couple years ago we started
this
food festival called family style it's
kind of an offshoot of the hundreds
and in in recognition that food has
always brought people together
right business meetings dates
right like warring nations they come
together over food
so if food is the thing that's always
brought people together and gotten
conversations flowing
why don't we get the best food uh that
we can curate and
invite all the different communities in
and that family style
has been very successful for that reason
but that was also another way that we
wanted to serve the community
we have another event in one week in
south la and we're working with all
restaurants from the neighborhood um and
you know we want to highlight these
establishments that are
genes of la food culture and also
showcase some movies like uh for example
mikey alfred from illegal sieve
we're premiering his new movie north
hollywood mikey was a part of that mid
90s
movie with jonah hill as well and so
look always trying to showcase the next
generation
the young kids the new brands and also
communities that haven't necessarily
gotten the attention they deserve
on the issues that need that they need
attended to
i love that i i love that for a couple
of reasons
one thing that i'm what i when i heard
that i'm a humongous fan
of changing my mind adjusting context
what's the common sense practical thing
when i listened to that that was
community building
on the reality of the moment so there's
a macro intent
and then you're just living and that's
kind of how i think about what i
what i believe in what i see works and
what works for me
which is whatever your your principles
are
how you see the world what you [ __ ] with
you never know i mean
i don't like i didn't see asian american
hate
brewing like this two years ago that
wasn't running through my mind like yo i
i'm sure in q1 of 2021 this is going to
be something that's going to mean
something to me
i just know [ __ ] bad [ __ ] and so
wherever i go
that's why when i hit when the whole
matters lives matters i'm like
yo of course all lives matter but let's
vote like right now
asian lives like like it's okay for it
to bounce around like don't
don't get hurt because it's not your
turn it's always your turn it could
always be
you never know what happens and so for
me what i like about what you're talking
about is the same way i think about
marketing i didn't know clubhouse was
coming
i didn't know nft was ready i've been
seeing it vr is something i look at
every day
ish aka i can go 90 days without looking
at it
but it is in my mind every day like the
shit's coming the shit's coming the
shit's coming yeah
and then one thing's gonna happen and
i'm gonna be like yo here it is
no different than you know nba top shop
or
crypto punks or things of that nature so
i think i think that um
what i really like about that and what i
want everybody in clubhouse and
watching on my live streams to think
about what bobby just said is
i think people are too micro it's
literal it's like this
and i think if you take it up much
higher and say this is my overall
ethos the context of the situation
is how i live it's kind of like being a
human being right like
people always try to box in brands
right which always like our brand stands
for i'm like that's fine
but like a very good one marty um
you know that's all that's all fine but
the reality is is you know
i have a funny feeling that ben hundreds
is different
than when he's with his inner family at
dinner right
then then he is at a complex con
trying to do a business move that he is
with his boys
in you know grease on a on a bachelor
party
versus versus like that one by the way
he react clubhouse reacted to that one
first smile we got from that definitely
he's definitely a different guy on a
bachelor party
he just is and he's a different guy when
he's with you know
you know everyone's different you're
different with your 11 year old daughter
than you are with your plus one than you
are with your
with your business partner like we have
layers and we need to let layers breathe
yes thank you i write about that in my
book too
just how brands can be trapped everybody
is you know brands are being consistent
doing the same thing over and over again
um the magic with our brand early on i
remember the first time i spoke at ucla
a kid stood up in the back we were only
a few years into the brand he's just
like how are you guys going to be
relevant
10 15 years from now and now it's been
15 18 years since then
and i was like look i'm just going to
continue telling our story
and the story is going to change because
we changed you have to allow
people to change you have to allow
people to make mistakes
you have to let people grow right we're
all
in actually bobby can i can i can can i
interrupt you for a second
yeah the ability to allow people to make
mistakes
yep what is ben zubin
bobby thoughts on the quick triggers
of society now right there's such a fine
line
with cancel life right yeah people are
headline reading
you're assumed guilty let there be no
confusion it's devastating
to me everyone's a suit i watch all i do
is read
it's rough yeah it's like like fake
allegations are guilty takes
years to clean like what where do you
feel the culture is in general right now
on
its ability to let people make mistakes
because it feels very difficult right
now
i have many thoughts on cancer culture
which i'm
formulating in an essay but
for one i don't think it's going away
anytime soon i think this is
just the nature i i don't blame the
people as much as i
blame the platforms and the way that the
technology is set up
and so i think you're going to by the
way on the record
you were going to be historically crazy
wrong about that
am i really yeah let me tell you by the
way or i am
this will be fun we're going to be 70
years old watching this clip and
someone's going to be laughing
i just i think i think i i think the
platforms are exposing
us i think i i'm a i think people
do not want accountability on our
behavior we love pointing fingers we
hate thumbs
i think people i i'm a very big believer
that when we have a decentralized social
network and the algorithms are doing
nothing
all the [ __ ] you're seeing will be
plenty there because plenty of people
are hurt
and want to hurt others in security if
you ask me what my number one hope
is before i die it's that i see society
get into a really
interesting relationship with insecurity
i think insecurity leads to
so much bad behavior in a million
different ways and that if we stop
demonizing bad behavior and we go deeper
kind of like we did with alcoholism or
drug abuse and we got more thoughtful
no longer you know i'm 45. you i grew up
as a kid where like oh that's a druggie
that's a piece of [ __ ]
and now there is thoughtful compassion
and trying to understand that
i think security insecurities the big
one
because i think it leads to a lot of the
behaviors that should be canceled
and the reason people go to places so
quick i think
okay i think this is an end or not an
ore moment i think
what you're saying eventually we are
going to get there i think
in the immediate now the reason why
it is so crazy to watch
is it's really the weight of the
internet i think if you messed up
in anywhere in your life you know in any
generation before this
your community comes after you right you
there's a scandal you do something wrong
your community comes after you
community at the time let's say was like
a couple thousand people a couple
hundred people
and now when your community comes after
you it's five million people
it's you know five billion people
sitting on top of you that has nothing
to do with platforms
that has to do with the internet not the
platform
on top of it okay so let me rephrase
that's the nature of the internet that's
the technology and so if you're gonna
accept that people can become successful
and famous overnight using the internet
then you also have to accept that people
can be crushed and fall off the face of
the planet overnight
as well like that is the other side of
cancelled culture
why are we celebrating people who become
huge pop stars
movies celebrities overnight but then
when they have falls from grace
overnight that we cannot
uh take that so you have to take both of
them those are both a result
of how the technology works uh but to
your point
i think it's gonna be
this is what we did to madonna this is
what we did to elvis right but now we're
all madonna
i always use these that's the best i get
i get it right that's a great one like
like that's what that's when four
four mega media conglomerate
juggernauts made decisions on who we
cancelled or not there was literally a
rupert murdoch
or a red subject who could stop us
canceling exactly
why some of the people got cancelled
first like so like
there's a catch-22 there's a great
russian saying
it basically talks about everything's at
its best when it's balanced
yeah and i think that's what i'm curious
about as we continue to stretch
yeah go ahead it's starting to interrupt
but
this is how i like it yeah i think this
is
we are getting to the place that you're
talking about this great valley which is
a place of better empathy and compassion
because all of us are going to need to
be broken first
i have this terrible fantasy it's a dark
fantasy
that somebody's going to hack into the
internet and expose
all of our search histories yes all of
our emails at the same time
all our texts it's at the same time and
when we're all naked and all [ __ ] we
all love them all naked
exactly i'm writing that screenplay
bobby i'm
i'm scary that's a black mirror that's a
black mirror episode
but that's what's gonna have to happen
in order for
uh us to reach that level of compassion
we're watching it happen to want people
one by one and every time i see somebody
throwing a stone at the glass house i'm
like
you're you really are next i love you
right i love it i got to go [ __ ] this
sucks
real pleasure zoo bean keep this going
bye clubhouse buy every livestream bye
bye gary
[Music]
that totally took a detour but yeah but
it always does like right it always does
scary especially yeah um all right let's
talk about something else let's shift
gears for a moment
so many people are listening and tuning
in right now they either have a business
they're starting a business they're
doing whatever they're doing with their
lives
and at some point in almost everyone's
lives they get to a point where they're
like i want to do something
most of the time and they think about
partnering with someone
i've gone through my partnerships that
have been great and the ones that have
been horrible and one of the things that
i realized is that
at the end of the day after you sit back
and look at it you're like
how much do i care about the other
person's success right
like the reason why i love working with
gary is because i want him to buy the
jets i want him to be successful and the
more i want him to be successful
in turn the more i'll be successful and
bobby i like
you mention in in in your book which i
think everyone should read i've got
multiple copies here as well i give them
out all the time because i think it's
just
and i can't wait until it's a show by
the way um but
you mentioned in your book in the
chapter around mac
and you guys you ben mack your
uh evening conversation everyone needs
to like read it i mean it's you you're
not gonna you're not gonna put this book
down
but you mentioned at the end of it the
end of that chapter
you said or you wrote the one person i
care about when it comes to the hundreds
is ben
i work my darndest to impress him and do
whatever i can to make sure he's
performing his best
every day can you tell us more about
your partnership and ben
how do you feel about it and just tell
us more about how your partnership works
what can people learn from your
partnership
um yeah look partnerships are really
hard
um bobby and i didn't know that we were
getting married
18 years ago when we started the
business but we partnership is a
marriage
and they're really hard you gotta work
towards them work on them all the time
and you know we uh i think that bobby
and i over the years
and early on you know we
um distinguished our roles
and we both help each other out when we
need it
but you know i work on my side of the
business
and bobby works on his side of the
business and
um you know i i i handle the business
end for us
and i have a ton of respect for bobby
because he's one of the best businessman
i know
and to know that he trusts me with that
um
really gives me the the confidence i
need to help run our business
right and um i hope i do the same for
him i think i do the same for him
bobby's the
the leader behind the creative side of
our business
and um you know i'm i do not think i'm
nearly as creative as body bobby but um
i think i
i know enough the you know i could be
there to support him and i really
believe him and i'm i'm his champion
um and support him to let him do his job
and
the the the trust that we have in each
other's visions for
our side of the business i really think
has helped us get to where we are today
um so yeah partner i mean to
to wrap that up like partnerships are
really hard and i think that um
you know as you're getting into it i
think the most important thing really is
to uh just make sure you know what your
role is
in the partnership you know to
also touch on what you said about um
about what you
[Music]
about how you want gary to succeed and
gary succeeds that means you succeed
that's absolutely true
and um you know bobby and i we we do
have this
bond with friendship and this
partnership to where
yes like the the bigger and better
uh that bobby does with uh with his work
it's that's better for me and i think
the same goes for him too that
you know the the more i do for us you
know it's it's better for us
it's the better i do it's better for us
and i think that those are all really
important parts to uh
to a successful partnership there's an
old um psychology anecdote
a marriage marriage therapist is sitting
in front of couples
and within the first couple minutes of
talking to them can tell you
if they're gonna last or not whether
they're gonna be divorced in 10 15
50 years or whether they're going to
stay happily married
and the therapist uh professed
the reason what trick would signif
signaled this for
for her was that uh
there was a lack of respect in the way
that
the husband would address the wife or
vice versa
and that is the glue right like that's
the the core of any marriage but also
every partnership it's respect and
the moment that there is um
a fluctuation in that respect there's a
lack of respect
you know i don't always agree with ben
in fact i disagree with him probably
more than i agree with him
right we fight argue at all the time
but i have so much respect for ben uh in
his position
and his role in the company that even if
i
am enraged at the decision that he made
i'm like i but i gotta respect the guy
right and so i try to uphold that in all
of my relationships
with my friendships with um you know all
my partnerships that i'm
in and the last piece i'll leave that
with is
if you're looking for a partner whether
it's in romance and business
any venture that you're getting into you
have to start by being a good partner
yourself
right the partnership is only going to
be as good as you are you cannot be
constantly looking to to the other
person to fulfill
whatever it is that hole in your heart
or whatever it is that you're supposed
to bring to the business like
that's on you and so i see a lot of
people get in trouble
other brands where they're constantly
blaming the other partner for something
or that i'm like yo that's
you that's your problem so you be the
good partner first
you know and as you work more in
yourself
right the other your partner will be
empathetic enough to work on themselves
and that is like the respect but um
you know yeah of course it's hard but
it's also like
the best thing ever like ben's my best
friend
we've been doing this for 18 years it's
like it's really not even about the
hundreds if you
look at the story again it's about the
people and it's really just like ben and
i at the end of the day
in the center of our building we have a
90 000 square foot building
here in l.a right there's like 100
people in the building right
all kinds of our visuals on the walls
our favorite photo they're in the center
of the building there's a photo of ben
working at his desk it's from 2006. is
that right ben
i'm shooting the photo uh yeah winter in
the january of 2006. yeah ben's sitting
there working at desk it's like midnight
it's like one in the morning
and i'm taking a photo from across the
street through the window and just being
like
this is everything this is our entire
universe my whole life is in here
there's been we had like seven t-shirts
that was our entire inventory
you know that was our first office and
warehouse and eventually became our
store and the store became
what you know fairfax and rosewood as we
know it today but
um every day i come to work and you know
i have a zillion things going on we're
working all these massive projects and i
passed by that photo and i'm like it's
still just that
still just a couple of 23 year old kids
who started a t-shirt brand
we're just having fun like it has never
it's never veered from that it's always
that
that's amazing and i think it also is
reflected in how you
um deal with and and work with
your clients or rather your colleagues
your 100 your vendors everything it's
not just the two of you
100 you got to be a good partner first
you know
you got to respect the people you're
working with there's if you don't feel
like you're being respected leave it's
not going to work
i don't want to say it again right like
i said it earlier but i think that
so much so many people in the world view
partnerships
view business view success as a zero-sum
game
and they're infinite opportunities and
once they shift that mindset and they
realize that
just because you're doing better doesn't
mean i can't also do better
or if i help you do better that doesn't
mean that i can't do better
it's a really important like mindset for
people to get out of this whole zero-sum
mentality
that yeah like everyone can do well
together
right yeah we were we were built on that
premise
right so when we started the blog i
spent nine out of ten posts and we still
do this
talking about other people other brands
and that mindset was so opposite
from how the first generation of
streetwear
had started where it was very
dog-eat-dog which is
the first generation of anything is
doggy dog there's only so much space
there's only so many customers
but when we came in we were like hey all
i
i'm more interested and curious about
what everyone else is doing because the
more i talk about them the more i talk
about huff or diamond or crooks and
castles or whatever brand it was
the the bigger the marketplace becomes
for all of us right the rising tide
lifts all boats and i feel like we're in
that same space again
with nfts right and like this new
movement with crypto art
the the strongest part of all of it is
the community
where everyone is just buying from each
other supporting each other
selling and minting for each other right
i'm just looking
in the in the in the chat right now in
the clubhouse but like zoe
who's an nft artist is the same way like
she
goes on last night on clubhouse talking
about her release like she just had a
big nft drop
all the people in the room are other nft
artists who are like go zoey like
we're behind you she's always out there
she's always supporting every time i
jump in a room she's always in there
like listening
like supporting all of us so um that is
the secret to all of this it's you know
is supporting your community
and supporting your supporters it's
brilliant
all right i'm gonna ask you one more
question on the youtube stream and then
we're gonna jump into clubhouse for all
you folks in clubhouse
we got a few minutes for uh you'd ask
some questions uh from the guys
all right bobby you've got a milestone
birthday coming up
oh my god where did that come from how
do you know that
well all i had to do was google it and
then i've got the same milestone
birthday coming up but it's not about me
it's about you
but okay everything kind of came
together for me as i was thinking about
this today and i'm like okay your mom's
one birthday is coming up
i can't help think about the
conversation that you had with a
battleman
yes yeah i told you to follow your
passion and that you've been so
successful
turning 40 and again what you have doing
what you love
can you talk about that a little bit
please yes yeah first i have to correct
you
in the internet it's wrong it's for some
reason it says my birthday's a year
later than it is um my 40th was actually
last year
however my 40s was last march 27th but i
will
say that it didn't count because it was
right at the start of lockdown
and it was the worst way to celebrate
40th where no one would even
drive by at that point so
next week is my real 40th so thank you
zubin
ben also celebrated his 40th like a
month after mine last year he also gets
another chance at it
um the the story that zubin's talking
about and i and i write about in my book
people have heard it a few times
when ben and i started we were we were
in law school
and i was still on track to be an
attorney and
that's that first summer after our first
year i interned for a research attorney
in the courthouse his name was abe
edelman
and i had a three-month internship there
and he was
basically my mentor and the first day
it was very apparent that abe was sick
and everyone knew that he was dying of
cancer we didn't know when but he was
dying
so i work with this guy intensely he's a
genius he's kind of a legend in the
courthouse all the other lawyers are
scared of this guy
and the last few weeks he kind of stops
showing up
he's really sick he really can't even
stand up straight
and uh i show up to my last day of the
internship at the end of the summer and
he's sitting there on a on a bench and
he's talking to all the interns one by
one and so i get in line
and i sit down with him and he says um
you know how did it go and i was
like yeah i mean that was great thank
you i learned a lot and he's like
you're one of the brightest interns i've
had in all the years of me doing this
um you're gonna have all the cars he
said he said it just like he said you're
gonna have all the cars all the homes
all the women right so like the plural
part of all that was just like
amazing like i'm in i'm gonna be a big
dog attorney
and um he looks at me and goes but uh
you should never be a lawyer and
i was so confused i was like wait am you
just said i did what did then
did i mess up somewhere and he's just
like no no
you're gonna be super successful as a
lawyer but you should never do it your
heart's not in it
and i was just like yeah sure it is you
know i've been coming to work every day
i've been
putting my sweat and tears just like nah
he's like what do we talk about when we
go to lunch
every day we walk down the street we sit
at the carl's jr the mcdonald's or
whatever like what do we talk about i
was like
um he's like you talk about this thing
you're working on called the hundreds
which at that time the summer of 2003
was not a thing
ben and i didn't even have one t-shirt
printed we didn't have a website set up
he's like you always take out your
blackbook you have all your drawings
all your t-shirts you're working on you
have your framework for your website
because i was building an html website
by myself which is what you did back
then
very analog um he's like that's what we
talk about is the hundreds and he's
like i don't know if that's ever going
to be a thing but the way you care about
that you're so passionate you love it so
much
it's like look one day you're going to
wake up and you're going to be 40 years
old like me
and you're gonna be dying of cancer and
are you okay with having spent
this entire life doing something that
you didn't truly love even though you're
gonna make money doing it
and um you know the the remarkable part
of that story well first it ended up
passing away a few months later but what
he did
in that exchange was abe gave me
permission
right no one had given me permission to
that point to do whatever i wanted
right my parents said you can't make a
living being an artist society
my teachers they're like you're never
going to make it oh you want to be a
fashion designer you're asian american
there is none
right so you're not even represented out
there like there's no blue there's no
road map for you
um and so no one said i could no one
gave me the permission
he gave me the permission he's just like
what do you want to do do that
somebody that i respected abe do it
right so then i gave myself permission i
owned it
i said i'm gonna do this this is what
i'm gonna do for the rest of my life
every day i have to wake up
and tell myself that every single
morning i'm brushing my teeth and i'm
like you got this
and the imposter syndrome in me is just
like nah you don't know what you're
doing you don't belong here you're a
fraud
and i'm like no i belong in the room i
should be in this room ben and i deserve
to be in this room why not
right and so he said every he said one
day you're going to wake up you're going
to be 40 years old
and are you going to be okay with the
cha the choices that you made
and i woke up 40 years old a year ago
and i sat there in bed and i was like
this is the day like i was talking to my
wife i was just like dave like this is
the day and
i'm very very happy with the choice that
i made i make a lot less money
than some of our lawyer counterparts
right like
ben and i have friends who have more
money than we'll ever see
and are very happy and successful
because that was what they were chosen
to do
but for me i'm very happy man i can't
dude the day the day that ben came to me
and said
hey we can make a we can make our rent
doing this
like that he might as well have handed
me three billion dollars i was like i'm
rich
i was like because it's not about the
money it's because i get to do
what i really want to do and i can
survive off of it
like that's it i can make a living off
of my art
that's it like you don't need to give me
more you can give me a yacht
like what am i going to do yeah it's
going to be parked out there while i
still come to work every day and get to
work on the project
so that's all you know that's babe story
bobby thank you so much for sharing that
i mean i think the audience
everybody on youtube clubhouse etc is
finally realizing if they haven't
already why i love you guys so much
i mean you're so brilliant and we're
gonna end let's end our
youtube just jump to clubhouse just
answer a couple all right
bye youtube world come on youtube world
all right youtube world come over to
clubhouse
you